I think fashion is reached a kind of
critical mass,
literally dumb ass.
I'm
good.
Taste is no longer a privilege,
like in home design,
you can get fantastic looking things for
your home and for you to wear and you
don't have to pay a premium for that.
So I think that that's great that,
that great design,
great fashion.
Um,
is it all price points now?
So I think it's reached all levels of
society.
So there's a kind of egalitarian idea
that fashion is no longer for the
privileged few,
um,
which,
uh,
resonates in my democratic year with a
nice ring to it.
I think that fashion is big business.
Um,
let's not kid ourselves when you open up
fashion magazines and see the amount of
advertising and the amount of money
that's put in there.
Women buy clothes and continue to buy
clothes.
Um,
and men are getting very involved much
more.
The men's side of fashion is growing at
a large rate as well.
Um,
the cosmetics business,
all of that,
a part of beauty which is an extension
of fashion in a way in how you look and
how you are,
um,
health and the way we exercise,
all of that has to do with our
perceptions of who we are.
A slight cult of youthfulness and
wanting to stay young.
I think that has made fashion become an
even larger,
more important role.
Um,
because if we dress like a ladies,
we're going to feel and look like old
ladies.
So keeping on,
keeping fit,
looking beautiful,
looking young,
staying young,
keeping current with what's going on in
the trends,
those are all part of a kind of cultural
shift and change were,
you know,
40 is the new 50 slash 50 is the new 60,
whatever.
Everyone's living a lot longer,
living a lot healthier and everyone's
allowed to,
I think tap into dressing in a way that
they never were before.
And the options are huge.
So you don't just have to have a chanel
suit,
you can,
you can do it any way you want to.
Um,
so I think,
I think fashion has become fun.
It's become acceptable,
accessible,
um,
and it means that good taste,
everyone can have it.
I think some of them are probably a
little arrogant and snotty about it and
would love to see it on five foot 11
skinny,
beautiful model,
um,
but I can't help but think of Karl
Lagerfeld who's so smart in and his,
again,
reinvention of what Coco Chanel did and
liberating women from corsetry and
giving them a loose shape,
jackets and sweaters and all sorts of
things that we take for granted now that
women never wore a before she came along
to kind of liberate us from the Corset
of,
uh,
of the 19th century.
I admire Karl Lagerfeld's ability to
continually reinvent that wheel.
And I think one of his great successes
is that he accepts the modern,
if it's going to be a jersey girl with a
really expensive handbag,
fantastic.
You know,
if it's a Russian oligarchs wife who's
got gazillion rubles and she can spend
it on slightly gaudy taste,
why not,
um,
if it's the women of oil barons that can
now a dictate and pay for couture,
um,
a book,
I think if to say no to that is folly.
You can't change the future.
You,
I think his philosophy's always been and
to his great credit,
embrace what's new,
find out what's interesting about it.
Take from that,
learn from that.
Keep your ears open and watch what's
going on.
Um,
and don't be too arrogant or complacent
about it.
I think designers have to keep their
ear,
you know,
everyone gets tired and complacent and
thinks that what they do,
no,
they lose,
they lose touch with what's going on.
And I think he would be someone that one
could channel to really appreciate no
matter who's wearing it,
listen to their customer,
they're buying it.
You know,
you're,
you're making clothes,
you're not reinventing a,
the cure for life.
You're making clothing.
So whoever would work can wear it.
Does where it.
Gosh,
how lucky,
unfortunately,
that someone wants to buy what you've
designed or made.